welcome back the children's Heart
Foundation is gearing up for their
fundraising event cards for kids to
support Vegas's littlest hearts and here
to tell us more and how we can all get
involved we have Dr Beth creel Dr Beth
thank you so much for being here thank
you so you mentioned you've been working
with the organization for 17 years which
is just so incredible thank you for all
that you do tell us a little bit about
this partnership in this event and how
we can all be part of it well we are
having this event Saturday night and we
raise funds for the children's Heart
Foundation the foundation helps our
families that we see and treat at the
Children's Heart Center
and the proceeds go back to helping the
foundation the foundation helps and
assists all our families
emotionally financially
scholastically in all different areas
and we just can't say enough about what
the foundation does for our kids they
really give them a second chance at
enjoying life after a difficult
diagnosis is made and events like these
they're so much fun and you're eating
and you're dancing and having a great
time but there's really a deeper message
here what are you hoping that people
take away from the event every year when
they come and support well this year
specifically I'm very focused on people
realizing the impact that a heart
condition has on a child very few people
know that the prevalence of having a
congenital heart disease is 60 times
more prevalent wow than Childhood Cancer
and that twice as many children die
every year from congenital heart disease
than all childhood cancers combined so I
want them to walk away realizing the the
intensity of the diagnosis I want them
to walk away remembering what they're
doing and how they're impacting all our
kids lives because our kids are warriors
and it's an incredible
um
the participation is incredible and then
I want them to leave repeating I want
them to repeat what they've learned and
what they've heard and what they've seen
at this event and all of the funds that
are raised they stay here locally so you
know that you're helping children right
here in our biggest Community exactly
and we help in all different areas so
yes in state there's so many things that
we can do in our own backyard with these
kids and the diagnosis that they get
well let's get people out there let's
tell them the event is happening this
weekend where can people get tickets and
are they still available tell us all the
details they can go to
chfn.org chfn.org to purchase more
tickets we do have tickets available
it's Saturday night the 8th from 6 to 9
and it's at the industrial event space
which is they've been amazing to us and
I hope to see everyone out there and I'm
just welcoming everyone again it's for
our kids and I thank everyone that's
been involved to this point well Dr Beth
creel thank you for everything that
you're doing in the community and for
spreading the word and we can't wait to
see how the event goes this weekend so
for more information that's right there
on your screen cards for kids it's
happening October 8th from six to nine
at the industrial for more information
you can visit that website and uh thank
you again for being here at Mercedes
I'll send it over to you